321 vai dar que falar e andar muito bem
vindos a maioria aliada muito calor de
fora
o 1 meu foco está na cama mas não só que
eu comprei tentava passar por uma loja
que compra isso eu acho muito importante
o que lhes bleus portman edson bastos
não tão bem vindo que assistem
brutalmente sua vez são as rodas por
vocês colocarem no nosso sapato nos
novos tênis vocês vão conseguir andar
com os outros temas como se buscar então
assim o fez comprar isto com essa imagem
o essa imagem e expor também estas
escolas fazem foi escaparem de fogo
quando vocês vão andar ser eu quero
muito apresentar estudos agora só tem um
pequeno problema um grande problema até
o peso máximo de 80 quilos 80 e eu acho
que vocês já repararam que o peso mais
de 80 quilos nexo aumentem e dinheiro à
conta que eu penso em punição ao mundo
mas muito mais de 80 que o santos está
ativa vai dar bosta neles já vou ter a
seguinte eu saí mas não quer ser o vôo o
nome de vida coloca muito bonito não só
correntes nas rodas e como podem ver com
os temas vão encaixar aqui e depois é só
apertar aqui o cordão eu acho que isso
não cabe no meu pé e outro agora
supostamente estavam e continuam a dar
passos física faz fogo e que nada mas o
fogo né não
eu acho que quando esta pedra bateu no
chão ela vai fazer essa tal política né
tudo e é de começar um vídeo pessoal
vamos tentar aqui bater uma meta para
tentar achar um saltinho mais neste
vídeo e eu vou fazer uma coisa bem a
capital eu vou pedir a alguém que tenha
carro aqui em casa e vou tentar uma
corda o carro e eu vou tentar ser puxado
por um carro enquanto nessas escolas vai
ser brutal limitou o caso passar um pito
tudo muito foi isso que o esgoto desabar
mostra mais bola sofre milagre
o motivo para uma idéia eu não sei se
alguém já fez vídeos com isso mas vou
tentar ver aqui um vídeo e versão de
ensino andar caiu só colocar os fóruns
são nem quer saber se vai juntar à léo
rodriguinho será o enterro
em tóquio pouco atrás enquanto patrão
países conseguem dar à luz na boa eu sou
eu fiquei o mundo escuro eu quero muito
fazer parte
quero muito ajudar a gravar agora o bei
sob um sol na rua eu te trouxe as partes
fazem feliz com a lei mas isso vou usar
depois porque o órgão só experimentar a
área que podem ver o que acontece e
ballack ataque vamos dar 32 pontos vai
muito equilíbrio ainda
funciona e vou tentar investir 1 grau a
primeira aventura começou agora a rua
está aqui porque o meu 2 vai mais
incrível desse negócio
meu muito é muita honra e ao fazer isso
agora já não vai conseguir de novo de
hoje estava já o lema todas a 6
eu tenho com o carro caso aprovado
fundiu crise
tudo bem e no final já atua ainda em
choque foi muito impressionante
eu tenho muita país olha aí está saindo
aí vai ficar muito mal isso mas eu não
vi isto só lá vou tentar outra vez bola
olha aí agora que o ronaldo vai
implementar agora pessoal eu andar de
patins com a criança então talvez eu
tenha facilidade não quero dizer que eu
vou conseguir mas talvez eu tenha
facilidade é bem estranho
agora fazendo o gesto deve ter pato deve
conseguir mas se calhar não sei
bom é assim mas tem que fazer é o pec
vai na frente
assim só mantenha assim que a primeira
queda vai ser agora porque eu vou me
arriscar queimado no chão meu pai eu
adorei
pensando em comprar um milagre eo
ronaldo vamos fazer umas ray conhecemos
muito bem e só vai tomar só tá combinado
agora o pessoal então é isso nós vamos
ficar porque com este vídeo para fazer
tenham gostado já sabem que devem assim
mas este tipo de coisas que por cautela
comandado
leões patins comitê e já sabe vamos
tentar chegar aos 100 mil leques neste
vídeo games e quem vai até a próxima